good evening and thank you for coming
this evening my name is David by service
director of the AIP Kirby jr. center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
project or Hillsdale College my pleasure
to welcome you this evening as we
celebrate the grand opening of this
facility the scripture says that unless
the Lord build it they labor in vain
open nowhere is that more true than in
Washington DC where every bit of divine
assistance is needed
as we march this grand opening we are
grateful for the divine providence and
the sustain this project hillsdale
college and our nation we are especially
grateful to the generous friends of
hillsdale college especially mr.
attorney who made this project possible
may I ask all members of pill sale
colleges presidents up please stand
we are very grateful to the men and
women who designed built and furnished
this place in particular we would like
to thank rockford construction mike van
dessel president of rockford is here
with his colleagues Roger we copy Joe
cute cat quarterman and Jason Johnson
with some 60 men from Michigan under
their watchful eye and a few from around
here that needed a little bit more
watching and after demolishing a
previous structure that stood here they
built this one brick by brick I think
the only time that superintendent of
this project Pat court and applause and
his work during the last 15 months he
and his wife event in residence here was
to talk about his admiration of Ronald
Reagan's courage and the wisdom of the
founding fathers with all of those from
Rockford construction
troop halt Amy Bowser and Kate Griffin
of jones lang lasalle helped to secure
this place trip a distinguished alumnus
of Hillsdale College was this generous
with his time on behalf of Hillsdale as
he was tireless in helping us acquire
this building trick me me Katy pure can
you please there
in accenture we'd like to thank the
architects of Wesley agreed with skalski
they were here earlier this afternoon
and also Vaughn and Terry Phelps of
God's design who did the interior
decorations we know their work from
campus I see it throughout this this
building as well we are providing a
constitution for future generations and
not merely for the peculiar
circumstances of the moment that was
said by James Wilson who's pictured
there up in this inking called the
signing of the American constitutional
investor Sam connect second from the
left as we viewed he sent men to wake
July 1787 during one of the many
difficult patches of the Constitutional
Convention the teaching of young people
future generations as Wilson call it is
the mission of Hillsdale College and
Ferguson and normally young people that
all those who are interested in serious
above their duties of citizenship and
also about the preservation of the
Constitution our speaker this evening is
one from whom meaning many of us in this
room and around the country have learned
so very much about the Constitution
about the Declaration of Independence
and about how these principles must be
taken together and that together they
stand as our only sure foundation Larry
are in the 12th president of Hillsdale
College is a teaching president and a
fighting President tooth he teaches
students and anyone else was interested
in learning and fights only those those
would you harmed the Constitution it
displayed his long-standing idea now
realized that Hillsdale are you from
Washington what no self-respect
from Michigan for nearly 170 years I
mean received his PhD in government from
the Fairmont graduate school dr. armless
director of research for Marco Professor
Martin builder the official biographer
Winston Churchill you can find that
ography now published by hillsdale
college press and its documentary
collection employer of this building
from nineteen eighty five hundred
thousand he served as president of the
Claremont Institute Southern California
as president until seven all
oh also on a constitution which is part
of the paw report until estate he heads
up the college's 680 million dollar
capital campaign the founders campaign
which will provide capital and endowment
goals that looks manly building schools
and grounds are liberal arts program and
the staff is also the Hillsdale Graduate
School of statesmanship which will be
based in missionary the recent election
might remind us of that old Kennedy
Nixon bumper sticker be thankful only
one of them to win dr. Ahrens commitment
to liberty his leadership of the college
and defense of the nation's enduring
principles reminds us of what
citizenship because the highest calling
brother Americans can mean please
welcome dr. Larry arm as he speaks on
the topic a constitutional platform for
America
hi everybody candy here is all upper
hand any point I wish were sometimes
because I'm ashamed I read Anna Jordan
roll column this week that a member of
the new majority in the house
represented a senior member is hired
himself a futures and that I will tell
you that I have not even looking for a
job in this town this whole building is
a labret lot so I can be involved with
out of the linear I like rather named
Bob able and wonderful people like that
and I do psych him he said scared this
place into its current state that's
doing Red Eagle us written work just
usually that's a grateful and also he
just bought his boss Doug Jeffrey input
there's wailing over there and shouldn't
cash bar and you get to know me with
that collagen find out its cause being
causes to be banned brothers and we are
very much that we'd like to say anything
if you want to find us there's this bad
thing amplified a soul and now that's
sort of the running place so I thank you
but I'm glad not to be working because
I'm a student was the Churchill and he
was fond of saying that the future no
human it is obscured so what a future is
to do for a living I don't know if we're
not coming to be experts about that what
are the coming forth and I'm going to
tell you that in four simple placement
I'm going to tell you a few simple
things about the Constitution and I
think these things but I'm going to tell
you are undeniable they are obvious and
they are mandatory I believe that we
must have these things or we must live
under despotism and I believe that's all
there is to it and i think i can tell
you what these things are about what
we're going to do some of the things I'm
going to say at least four or just
credentials the main credential we have
to be involved in this town is that
we're teachers and if you're a teacher
something happens to you I can tell you
from my own life for most of my life
when I was in graduate school doesn't
feel free and all a bunch of people I'm
just one of the ones who never want to
be a teacher so of course i am the
president of college and if you do that
for a living teaching is an excellent
relief but it comes over you this year
teach people the first thing about it is
you have to begin with the simple and
obvious and not forget that but the
second thing is you have to dig into it
and you can never get too far away from
the simple in the audience because
students are river there's a whole bunch
of students in my
this room right now students of my first
a tour that I can see in my language
site and what as they come and they go
and you always start at the beginning
you always start at the place where you
have to start and what's wrong with the
city is that we do not there is such
place about that beginning we're going
to bring some information about that on
some material and our first admission
perception in this in this room
admissions is a tournament in hillsdale
college the college has all the way it's
remote the town is small there's nothing
to do it's freezing home it is not on
coast East colors for all the elite
colleges is knocking west coast for the
survey yes everything is great about it
because you can only you should only
come they're also the colleges
because pastime I'm jealous about to get
expanded everybody is taking exactly the
same thing and it's hard what's the
television on sunday starting left
tackle is a review for the Oakland
Raiders he said six six foot 8310 he's
the only one who started it but a tackle
in eight in the NFL right now and last
year in May he completed the last course
he had to take in our core curriculum
and he did the work just like everybody
else and he stood out like sore thumb ok
and so when we have our admissions thing
I'm going to look at that painting I'm
going to say to me I told by is gonna be
standing alone in this room college
right now and I'm going to say what's
that and some ways that all the three
and tell me I'm so what else was done
and somebody will probably know that the
deck
was also voted on inside you that same
room and I'll say tell me about a
declaration of independence and somebody
might now and makes me I'll get somebody
to mention laws of nature and of
nature's God and then I'll ask them what
that is when Dad Clarence college I see
his wife said no their friend of mine
when he was up for a confirmation one of
the questions they asked him was Bernie
got this odd idea of the natural law two
different centered asking that question
he didn't tell them where it is I mean
you know it is by way you know when the
horse humans have comes necessary for
one people to dissolve the political
answer
another edison powers we are separate
equal station to which the laws of
nature and of nature's God entitle there
were 300 lawyers in that room that's why
nobody there is i'm going to say before
i'm finished the dispute about not the
meaning of that term there is a dispute
in America about whether any such term
can be anything if we are in the
business of taking these so how do you
go big 200 and some young people to be
in here and lay some small percentage of
into our college and then torturing them
for four years and relation defy the
laws of nature and of nature's God the
way you do that is you ask them to say
wait for the answer and then no matter
what they say you disagree and you make
them argue it until it becomes their own
we are accustomed to searching put as
reality of things we think the things
that we've and that's a dramatic
statement because ask a young person
today what it means for a thing to be
anything it's the cutest trick in the
world and I worked in over and over
again to get some perspective students
who named what their favorite subjects
and then just ask anyone that is what do
you want to study history what is this
to make a little sugar on wow it is
ecology that's a hard one to answer
takes a long time to figure out the
definition and they want to say in this
day and age like all the hoes don't get
your smiling right now here's old
callously translate and they and they're
all smiling on I just they've all been
tortured like this and they want to get
in before this nights out but here's
what they I want to say you don't want
to say you want my opinion and they'll
say according to whom or they'll say if
i come to your college are you going to
respect my opinion and we're going to
say i'm going to
no we don't give a crap about that and
the reason we don't is the question what
is politics is not a question about your
opinion it's a question about something
outside her pain there is not even that
is the nature of things the human being
the only creature blessed with the gift
of speech can therefore be more
connected but also his moral sense
arrests from this gift and because of
that moral sense of that graph
connectedness we always live under law
and the question in law is always the
question what is the just and what is
the unjust and you have to teach young
people to take that seriously so that
they can give and by the definition of
those terms and gives you doubt that we
suffered a today from the fit to know
the definition of such crimes I'm going
to read you something from January I
apologize in advance in a minute but we
believe that the claims were made there
on that day that if they were true then
then they are true now that is what they
said but if they are not true now as is
he accepted me that they were not true
then you have to choose we are going to
have this kind of government
according to these principles are we
going to have that kind at the two are
incompatible and that I'm certain as a
matter of fact that can be shown and is
shown every day in the classes it'll
fill college because it is the purpose
of the college since 1840 or to do it
and that brings me to my last point
about what we're going to do here it's
pretty simple I can tell you the
college's it is great for colleges a
beautiful place you should come to see
it but it has a romantic designing and
kids on one bus today by and large and
if you can get into our knowledge there
are two thousand colleges America if you
get in our College you get into about
1950 and half of making it into the
other and that's going up all the time
and so why do they come and subjecting
ourselves to all that maintenance in
trouble well there you go anywhere and
they would tell you when you go you're
so smart or so brilliant you can say
whatever you want to say we have
everything for you our purpose is for
you you need right why don't they come
to us you see they would come because
the velocity versus the men are drawn to
the good and most powerfully they're
drawn to the highest form of the good
they are drawn to a beautiful and I'm
saying that what happened in that pain
is view it is the most beautiful
political thing that is very candid and
the love of it
is inspired by the knowledge of it and
I'm saying if that knowledge is
confident and gained in this town just
as kids from Florida kid from California
Upper Michigan actually we're gonna
shoot it's more honorable
then so I predicted already happening by
the way people will walk across that
distance from those office buildings up
there and they will come over here to
face the question what is the foundation
of what they're doing because that is
the question actually answered by
convincing this answer successfully all
will be well and if it is not answer
successfully we will lose our freedom
but we're not going by the way perish
the thought we like to say by the way
that things are so complex today in
America look at that picture you know
whatever you just as in the faintest
moment afford in that room where they
signed the Declaration independence just
as at that moment they were doing
something that had never been happen
happen before in all history they were
the first time they had just formed an
army and they made it the Continental
Army and nobody knew have been to
Carnival they couldn't be dead certain
it wasn't kind they know what a long way
back when it's actually 25 years later
representing the United States of
America went across the pond and came
back told story what it's like that was
complicated what they do but they had an
eye and a mind for the simple and
abiding truth and they built themselves
were out there I will tell you my way
that there is a way to predict the
future you can't see the future you
can't live in any moment except right
now whatever I said a minute ago will be
dispersed it's the next thing I say the
thing I say right now it's no good even
if you know what I said before was it
but the past you know it's fixed and you
can see it and if you can find anything
in it that is providing the truth you
then we'll have predicted the future is
it must persist president church all I
can say you know if there's a thing that
can't go on but it won't he thought that
about communism if it's a saying it must
have one but it well that's for sure
things are serious it's worth mentioning
it's not just an ethically oh that's
very terrible the numbers are simply
staggering and they come after 60 years
70 years really a relative peace and
prosperity and they're about to surpass
the debt that we got in large or in
history and there may be a war coming
you've been reading papers and the
question arises if the world war how
would we get the finance to localize the
way we did last time and you know if we
have a war the powers that we would be
fighting are as barbarous as the powers
that we fought last time they're very
bad and the fact that you need to single
out the powers but you know well take a
lot of them North Korea by the way to a
tree bark there because they can't get
food and that's the policy and China
supplies that their electricity and a
lot of their water and doesn't seem to
check that
they're doing but Chinese you know they
do have an official church advance the
law saying who God is and it has the law
saying what the scripture is it's only
the very elect wrench and they let
people go to other churches a lot and
once in a while when it pleases them in
the experts of it then they break into
the houses for people are going to their
little churches that are not the
official church sunday during about the
street they break their backs and they
leave in line there that's a misuse of
course and they have a lot of course
they've been assembly legged and the
point is we weren't broke in 1941 and
we're kind of roughed up more than that
this is reason why we fight so well when
we fight like my college has this
fantastic military history right now
probably true the pound-for-pound a
number for number nobody has as many
kids going into those
as we do and they can't get any money
from the pleasure father in our College
because it's which is the military
government with anonymous and yet they
still got wonder they go home with the
same reason americans hi that is insane
if you set up an economy where people
become responsible themselves and that
means they let go to compete then it's
cooperate with others and they get
invested in society and they get a
chance to learn things that are the most
beautiful things to love then the most
danger Brett they really try for an
American soldiers they really fight and
the trouble is if you disrupt the
principles of that society and you alter
its institutions fundamentally as is the
announced purpose of current policy you
might change that relationship and so
forgetting whether or not we have the
means to fight a war if a war comes we
might let the character Sunday in the
future to do that heaven forfend so I
think that these urgent reasons are the
reason why we lost and also they provide
the opportunity why we can think about
the fundamental things an obvious list
of ear open for you they're not very
complicated
when I was young in graduate school I
got lucky I got a phone I got lucky and
I got connected to some people to a
really brilliant as they ain't got lucky
and got some connected to some people
we're trying to figure out what went
wrong with lust cuz you know the
greatest political philosopher in Europe
one of the three boys arguably greatest
got any Martin Heidegger a great teacher
all great minds [ __ ] he was a Nazi and
some of the students were Jews and they
ran for their lives from their teacher
relationship and then make people make
what's going on we better rethink but
the same time the conservative movement
was get started and so it was like this
I remember hearing the argument it is
the authoritative argument on
surveillance cruel that these great
thinkers to turn first back study in
fact revolution and one of their points
was they said that first independence is
good but it doesn't really say what form
of government we should have it's not
really tired
tution the dead person has a passage in
it that says that the people may alter
her abolish the form of their government
and they may establish new government in
such qualms is to sing to them shall
must like would be to effect their
safety that's what it is and so what the
conservative scholars were setting in
those that it was you can have any kind
of government now my teacher was about
11 goes and he's very contentious
managing Harry Jaffe still alive
excellent and so he was saying something
different but I remember that seem
reasonable made of the hard hang to get
to the bottom and the reason is we were
in a certain state at that time I'll
tell you what it was like as a master
author Solzhenitsyn writes about the
early days the some does some about
literature is an essay called is
breathing and consciousness returned and
it's about a SI x sakura that was
compromising with the claims of
comic-con barrier and sakharov was
primitive and in refuting him the
structure that Solzhenitsyn gives to the
essay is we've been people asleep and in
a dormant state we have lost the real
meaning of things that had been obscured
by a militant philosophy but now we are
waking up and still groggy
as breathing and consciousness returned
we make some mistakes and there were in
those days a lot of stinks maybe but
I'll tell you it's a generation later
now and just when you needed the meaning
of constitutional government is clear
there's been in recent years the debate
about whether the declaration of
independence has any information to give
or any relevance to the Constitution and
many conservatives are you than it
doesn't and i am going to argue right
now and it will take long don't you
actually don't even really need the
Constitution to understand the
principles of prostitution all you have
to do reach the first of areas and I'm
saying that you really carefully you
will find out that there is but one way
to form government so that your freedom
can be secure there are not two ways and
we will either return to that way i'm
randall about this there's a really
great girls professional staff is just
lost by a mr. a racial attorney general
in one of our state's and we have dinner
after i said this crazy say too much
congressional staffers which is one of
things we do here and she said you
really think we can go back to living
under the Constitution i said it doesn't
matter what I think about that what I
think is that a must there is but one
way I said maybe a second way to use a
little better really doubt that there is
a same way in being what they are what
human beings being what they are to
organize the government so they can
protect us and not oppressors those are
two different and very difficult
requirements and both are necessary you
must have a very strong government but
if you're going to have
strong government it must be parking us
in such a way that it will not become
their oppression there are 1300 i was
going to recharge the solvated before I
go I want you to know that what put us
to sleep but obscure the meaning of the
Constitution and of the declaration is
this doctrine of history which also by
quite as far as cognitive international
socialism and in America the form of
that doctrine is called progressivism it
is the idea that your consciousness is
formed by the circumstances around you
doing Jim read John do it like ego if
we're not if we employ conception and
historic relativity nothing is clearly
then that the conception of Liberty is
always relative to forces that at a
given time and place are felt to be
oppressive now if you take that apart
for a second I'm a little bit long but
it's easy he says that resolve these
forces and the plug so that's one of the
things that make us think what Liberty
is and the other thing is our feelings
right what they're felt rested in other
words your victim of the interplay those
two things and that means that you can't
make an absolute statement about what
freedom is there's the sky Frank window
he's my favorite progressive because
he's so clear
sure
he was a college teacher he was a long
time professor at Columbia Columbia and
thanking that he was president and Johns
Hopkins and then he was one of the
founders in American food science
association of which I'm proud to be a
member keeping bad company hit their
convention like her into the stronghold
and Mondale got ninety-four percent and
a training got less than half the rest
so one night for us old friends of mine
all the burgers you come on his food
we're sitting around best having a drink
and but I've long since given matter and
and we decided to see if we could name
every political scientist who is
corroborated for us and we could
nezumi man Jeffrey no I'm almost now see
Franklin now started this thing and I
don't have to go from me but I can
reproduce it he says and remember he
gave his life to teaching he says we
teachers perhaps think to welcome
ourselves because whatever we chase them
both economic conditions come along to
change and determine what day the cry of
despair the freedom of the mind and
somehow that is thought to be the
foundation upon which we liberate the
government from the chains of
constitutionalism because it actually
does follow from this doctrine of
materialism and dependency in the
thought of these progressives that if
nothing is true then we should liberate
ourselves to make our own truth that's
by the way my kids today think that
everything that they see is really on
going on in their minds they don't like
anything is real you know I'll say the
ones [ __ ] did I break your nose is that
real we can't do that I said why not
mine are let's announce I'm your wiggle
aren't you you see the point with the
point
we are claiming you know what your bosun
lights this you can't have these checks
and balances there in the way you have a
great scientific effort what's going on
in the country you know that the
strongest single force actually i'll get
to that hurry I've k minutes I'm going
to take just that time there are 1320
words in the Declaration of Independence
not counting the signatures you don't
want 770 of the moba bad stuff the king
did and I would like to think that
that's having to throw it because you
remember that beautiful pair of first
paragraph that I quoted from it you
remember we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal and endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights secure these
rights governments mystic among men
deriving their just powers from the
pacifica miss Majesty
that language by the way we made the
world that language Congress is cognate
that language took it way we came the
freaking xin hearts and we think the
complaints in the middle cuz you know
way in so beautiful too because it's
like war thing means all those guys that
were remember how many are in that room
citing the Constitution also signed the
Declaration 12 or 13 I think and the
point is those guys in that room in the
decoration it's the same road base right
necklace and connect our hair if you
want to paint it truly is a plus and not
historic trip and because he thinks
glorification is not enough anymore you
might have true to go that's how you'll
get the real glorification that's what's
a thought you made that thing and the
what is there in that room and in the
lessons they appeal to divine providence
for the rectitude of their intentions
and they pledge to each other their
lives of their fortunes of their sacred
honor it's very grand up DNA so high saw
fierce in particular at the beginning it
so Universal and extracted from anything
about them it's a forever document again
it's us right here right now standing up
of the beer for ever again what comes in
the middle
the king did and there is a complete
account of that of constitutionalist in
that now from the con under twenty eight
paragraphs and by the way twelve men are
about stuff the government has to do and
16 of them are about stuff the
government may not do under the
circumstances and if you take those 28
things you actually have a government
you actually have elaborated and made
her own yes a consistent and beautiful
the Constitution United States and it's
there in the Declaration abilities what
are the principles the government must
not sorry I think what ask me first no
the government must not obstruct the
representative character of the girl you
know the king was that he would abolish
the legislature he would have pointed he
would tell them they got me document the
hills at sheboygan nobody think it
wasn't even a sugar in here and he would
go they had to me he would say they can
say somewhere we can see them they can
get to we have a right to our
representatives and two representative
government and the government was not
destructive no power in the government
can obstruct that in the end the world
hands upon us that's what it says by the
way do you not have also made today
actually you know and I would probably
some of you but maybe don't fall out
changed on what actually happens is you
know the thousand page deal whatever it
is it's 2000 hours it has scheduled a
billion trillion thousand about 2,000
but the thousand page bill is not a law
and not just because somebody can read
it 1000 page bill is also not a law
because what it is is a grant of
authority to a continuously meeting
legislature and the regulatory agencies
which also are the judicial and
executive branch unto themselves in each
area policy James Madison write some 60
second bitterest it will be a little
avail to the people that the laws are
made by the end of their choice is the
laws be so voluminous that they cannot
be read are so incoherent that they
cannot be understood if they'd be
repealed or revised before they are
promulgated are undergoing an excessive
changes every day Oh in this city who is
it by the way do you know that this is
about
building that's been built in Washington
DC in a generation who doesn't look like
a home you know what you know what word
bureaucrat means it comes from the
French word for that kind of desk that
they told pigeonholes you know imagine
such a desk with little pieces of paper
at all these little pigeon holes and it
like a roll-top desk well call the
government buildings look like that and
what's in there is little people you
know they kind of material things right
go look at the detailing of the
Department of Education and now they
kept those little up they built them
that originally sporting goods work on
the going ahead with little mini ridge
school houses on the front but the
building just looks like this big filing
cabinet for people and the rent things
I've always thought it's the classic
lipstick on me point is that that's the
second point when they complain about
the king that get bringing a crystal he
disrupts the center it's supposed to
make the laws and it's supposed to me
and that means by the way if you elect a
bunch of people and they meet somewhere
where they can get to and you were you
can see them then it follows that that
the only make so many laws because if
they have to think them through and they
have to do instead of gradient authority
to permanent bodies that meet night and
day 360 days a year thank God their
productivity
is low but that's how the huge screaming
it's importantly then he gets to this
breakdown separation of powers one of
their most vicious complex hot most
hostile angriest compliances he keeps
messing with the judges and that's so
good because there's this protection in
our system when the arm of the bowl
freezes up for you you have to go before
the fella who's paying cannot be changed
and it could not be dismissed from
office and he gets to decide your case
and he's outside all the rest of the
operations of government and the kings
of England by the way were the best
Kings on the continent very early and by
the way that ain't saying much and it's
kings they were forever missing it the
judges and the doctrine cut sharp in the
history of that that you ought not to do
that the judges you will point them and
you let them judge and then the fact
that they're different from us they're
the independent Sheree and you know if
you're a bond holder of Chrysler you
know that that that's gotten messed with
in this country in recent years by the
executive branch of the government which
is the most dangerous breach of
separation of powers and that's in the
declaration that you can't do that it's
the cause of the revolution so already
we know there have to be legislators
they have to make laws they have to
represent us the execution of the laws
has to be
from that and the judges have to be unto
themselves and independent and they
can't be themselves part of the ball
making and they can't be themselves
could coordinated by our control by
either those who make or those who
execute the law our safety depends on
that says Thomas Jefferson who by the
way in Paris when they wrote the
Constitution the last thing is a big the
government has to be subordinate to the
society now that's a hard conception
that I can probably make it plain and
maybe quickly Madison says in the
Federalist Papers that this is the first
purely represented for government and
think what that means that means that
the king was the sovereign and he's the
executive branch or in essence the
people with the sovereign and they met
to pass the laws we change that and you
get two advantages if you change it the
first advantage it is it means that
there has to be a step taken before we
can act before the sovereign can add
that means we can all get head up about
something screening and carry on its
throw fit but but then we can get around
to put a law about it would probably
believe calm down that's why you get a
terrible
it's all a load on the air every time
something comes up you see and the
founders are full of that kind of talk
the first thing you get in is that
medicine rice it is the reason alone
that must be placed in control of the
government the passions must be
controlled by it and that means this
representative represented principle is
the first safeguard against hasty or
sudden action the second one is we all
get to go make a living we don't have to
be in the government it means that every
other year we can have a big phone and
we got to get geared up to that we gotta
think of my way the wants to have it to
the American people opinion polls change
regularly and systematically as we draw
near to questions but something follows
on this and that is you get these two
great strengths of a representative
system but you get a danger because if
the government starts becoming a large
force unto itself in particular in
elections the danger arises that
sovereignty to pass from the people into
the government what is the largest
course I was
in electoral politics today the source
of money what is the other way public
employee unions that is to say
self-interested people who have a stake
in the side of the government the GSA
five in the two or three months after
September 11 2001 was there a huge fight
about you that in terrible bad bird and
and the Commerce insisted that the TSA
be converted into public employees and
the class that was reached to get the
building ultra was okay but there's
security officers were forbidden from
unionizing that has been changed in the
last six months and so they are you
involved coming up anything I think it
was robbed love article said nothing
good happens when you see somebody
wearing rubber gloves
now what are these objections to the
king in this regard you read that it's
really great you know my way I just
figure all this stuff out as I go along
as I think it's the Constitution bars
these little kids they ask you all this
stuff and you got to try to come up with
the answer what is it he elevates the
military or civilian he sets up separate
tribunals and it's mock trials they say
that's a term in the declaration for the
military and sometimes civilians are
placed under it or they are city broad
transported to England to get tried for
a crime not on their beers before he
says this large bodies of troops have
been brought all of us including many
foreign mercenaries and you know what
they say a bill of rights provision
about quarter in troops when the troops
showed up in Boston to fly Bishop to put
a stop to be cut up there they brought
an order that said the troops these new
truths and occupy the barracks of the
militia you know the militia is the
bestest citizen body a rest all men in
the citizen body are in the militia and
they take the barracks of the militia
that means the force there's been sent
to suppress us gets to use our own
resources you see overwhelmed by the
representatives of the government and so
our society is threatened by this
developer
but the next thing by the way and I want
you to know it's only really crazy hard
like people who ever mention this
provision of the Declaration but what
I'm telling you is it's hard substance
of the whole thing it's not specially
it's like the second way that the
Constitution is not a particularly
special thing is what the Constitution
is Mike it's the point that kind of
thing here's what they said erected and
multitude of these offices and sent
hither swarms of officers to harass our
people and eat out their substance now I
don't it's not like haha history repeats
itself I'm saying in a society like ours
we are vulnerable to that type of thing
it means that professionals in their
great numbers can be such an influence
in our politics that are free and
independent and disinterested that
doesn't punish that it means not
conflicted interests but this interested
vote becomes impossible now if these are
the main purposes of American
constitutionalism and they are present
in their twenty eight paragraphs in the
Declaration it becomes easy then to
write the workings and makings of a
constitutional platform for the country
and you don't have to put anything about
policy into it it's simple we just did
this by the way we're going to give it
to you tonight it's any priors so you're
the first one night
seventy thousand three it has four
points and I want you to know we really
only have these levels we're going to
teach these four walls it's the business
of the government protected Equal and
unfamiliar rights of individuals if you
examine and think about that for a while
you don't actually have to read a lot of
documents although they're wonderful
breathable will give them to you did you
just think about the meaning of equal
and available products you're going to
see the truth of Madison's prescription
the Equality man does not persist in any
accidental attribute that is common
color not even insects it is in
rationality and it's in London guess
that means no mate my government rather
than as any man my vitamin govern a
horse that's Thomas Jefferson but the
second thing also follows and you can't
get away from this there can't be a
natural
to anything that you enjoy it it deprive
others of the gullet and we have James
Madison writing explicitly that on many
occasions including painlessly and
essays wrote entitled property husband
writes that we shared pray for sure to
position to assemble to talk to speak to
spit on your spit on somebody or i guess
the sidewalk those rights we can all you
open all I wanted we can all have our
own problem and have you enjoyed other
and not have to take anything from
anybody else and those understandings of
Rights breathe tummy and the society has
this other understanding of rats that
now we have expanded rice now we define
new rights now we have Brides that
involve a claim of us against others the
effect of that is that makes some people
it sets a friction between people that
way some people powerful at the expense
of others and you can't have limited
government so the first principle is the
existence of the American government is
justified only by the existence of our
rights and once you say that and think
about it you know Bryce economic liberty
is inversely proportional government
spending and intrusion into our lives
and that means free government is going
to be cheap that's it and it doesn't
make any difference how rich the society
is because the society is to be a grant
eyes at the expense of the government
economy and government in all of its
methods has got to be and nothing else
from enemy that means Reagan was right
and Liam was right and Washington was
right the prosperity of the country is
the business of private people working
and by the way they work
and if you know them all she said
they'll just be mad at you and depended
on now it does mean that these
entitlement programs that we've spent so
much money on we have to protect our
investment we can't squander that
investor that means we should I pass and
in the name by the way and with the
certainty of preserving the value in
there because we have spent some very
much on and to lose that movie set back
and a tragedy that we could never afford
the third thing is national security is
the prime function of the government
after its regard to individual rights
are going to go under that lasted it's a
point to understand you stick our
Constitution course because you'll learn
something about the federal government
mistakes because it could take it first
to rename veterans and then you make
your federalist anybody say sure enough
that states are more trustworthy what a
million says states have rights the
reply of the Federalist is not the
federal
trust me that's not what they say they
say a individual separated stone and
made every exercise of authority by
every human being even in solitary and
single breast is only good if it is
restrained and directed to the good and
that means none of the state
government's northern federal government
is to be trusted but the balance the
trailer and the dimension of protection
that can be wonderful effective if you
decide to use later language but
government at the national level from
the administration of things at the
local level you can have a more powerful
government at the central level without
danger obstruction of your agreeable
what's in a way of the defense of this
country and the defense of the rights of
the people in this country is all this
mess that's located in all these ugly
buildings that are located around here
if you see a beautiful building in
Washington DC what is going on inside is
constitutional and vice versa
so what you do about the relation
between the federal government and the
stages you would notice two things that
internet make an interplay and we want
that infant went back the first is that
the Constitution guarantees a federal
government republican form of government
in the States and it says in the 14th
moment that they may not infringe the
privileges and immunities of citizenship
that's on the one hand and on the other
hand states have a constitutional
standing independent of the federal
government and their prerogatives and
authorities not rights under the federal
constitution must be protected and
including those in the ninth inning the
ninth step right
national security there are 17 clauses
in article one section eight nine are
about national two things but mainly it
goes on you're supposed to be natural
and more if it was China would not
because you know and you would have to
spend a lot more than bad right now but
goodness sakes we're near broke and
we're cutting the defense budget which
by the way shouldn't be at its existing
level unless we need if we need it it
should be whatever level it should be
and so the idea that the budget
constraint would make you cut defense is
exactly the wrong way to approach it
defense is about necessity finally the
restoration of a high standard public
and private morality is essential to the
revival of constitutionalism and that
means the posture of the federal
government toward religion and morality
is stated in the third of our for
organic dollars but on who started
religion morality and knowledge being
necessary to good government and
happiness of Bangkok schools and the
means of Education
be encouraged that's a statement about
the posture of the federal government
the existence of the of the first of all
organic laws the vector is the
dependence of the laws of nature and
nature's God is another but there is no
mention of Education in the Constitution
of the United States and I can tell you
from direct visiting there there is no
one in the art of education that I can
find some notes what it is I mean ask
them they can't tell you and so it is
not the administration of such things or
the regulation of such things there's to
happen in this city it is organized
rather to pay respect to such things and
let the states and the people in the
state's organize them for themselves now
I'm just going to close by saying this
there are four simple opposition's I
think that they are all just fine in the
concert sees the United States and I
think that they are all justified a name
in the Declaration of Independence and I
think you have a dependent of time when
it is said a thousand books i said but
relation between decoration constitution
about the need for evolutionary level
and the point is if you start with some
simple points you can evaluate those
arguments and there is this force in the
country called the tea party and it
actually knows more about the
Constitution
then the typical person walkins troops
in this town of my experiences a guide
although they're getting better in an
account so what if we could have an
argument that stemmed from and was
grounded in a teaching experience what
if we actually read I can tell you is
about 180 people on congressional staff
for your life regularly
right now love it just like the kid to
come from Florida the suffering
miserable cold energy so I'll close that
and just competition as you can see the
beauty of what happened in that road you
can only see it if you understand what
happened in that word but that is not
beyond the power of understanding of any
ordinary system if they do understand it
label love it and then the question of
its recovery will cost possible again we
are in the teaching that
yeah very high thank you we are actually
going to save our country if anybody has
questions or comments I'll be glad to
listen and respond yes sir yes I had a
specific question about the enumerated
powers of Congress as it applies to the
economy many of our politicians or many
of our elected leaders are saying well
the economy is that their major issue
well one area where it is i think is an
international trade but i don't think
that just because something is
constitutional it's necessarily wise
because several years ago congress voted
for most favored nation traits that's
for china now since then we've been
billions of dollars in debt to China you
mentioned some of the treachery of China
plus way if we go to war we may have to
borrow from China in order going for and
in cubo we have the general secondly
just voted to condemn United States for
sanctions against Cuba and I know
they're considering the freedom of
travel to Cuba act and Congressman Paul
just for that but the castro pirates or
weather's fine person aiders i'm not
sure which have been in power since
nineteen fifty-nine for most porn so do
you think that everything that's
constitutional is necessarily wise or
shouldn't be a teacher prudence that our
leader should have well the specific
answer your question is easy no i don't
think that everything is the candy
would be wise about the thing you asked
about there are very honorable people on
both sides of the free trade issue in
American history the greatest of our
statesmen are divided on that question
and i joined those who were for free
trip and so what i would do about China
is I studied Churchill anyway it was for
terrace and Churchill is for free trade
when I'm great what I'm doing you got to
make the choices but down but what I
would do about China my own devices is I
would trigger them at all I would do
both and also I would cut wasteful
spending cuz we don't borrow their dough
and I don't actually think I mean you
know I know I have me on what to me
actually my friend mr. stick vixen
they're looking full our value really
great content regional and but here's
what making what they teach me is pretty
light adults a pretty face to teach this
what it's a journal office here's the
trouble of channels the first one is you
can only really hurt somebody else by
hurt yourself if you do that it simple
in Dominica cheaper for you than you
might get except in very narrow cases
where you just got to have it to defend
yourself like if they're making all your
bullets
but another narrogin then if you spend
more money to make yourself in your
floor that's the first thing but the
same thing is I worry about the
political effects of tariffs because the
essence of law strikes me this way I
like this part of the American tradition
better than the other part of why did
well over held and air to right tariffs
are constitutional under the American
Constitution is it Karis have to favor
some people in the society and not
others and the ones they favor they have
a favor them at the expense of the
others that's just meant that's just
logic and arithmetic and so if you have
tariffs on food than the people who
produce food about to get richer and the
people who buy food we're going to get
corner and that by the way you know the
Greg DeMint in the building of an equal
democracy constitutional democracy and
angie is called the repeal of the Corn
Laws those are the taxes on food and the
reason they were politically difficult
was the Praetorian party was the party
of the land
doctors say and they were richard land
ginger that's a naughty aristocracy and
so people paying taxes on food so they
can get richer still another Disraeli in
winston churchill slaughter and later
winston churchill they turn against that
and i think that was a good move and as
you deliver sorry I'm going on too long
about this but if you deliver into this
city more of that kind of authority of
course they wake up play then what are
they going to do it they're going to
sell lon should be impartial
supposed to do and what also is her
opinion of a similar to the magistrate
versus having a brief reference for
example
let me see that let me turn a phrase
look at such young me what do you say
stadium behind their their thing so the
first question is oh I think of the
article Confederation it was a miserable
government and it played in reason it
failed is because it couldn't learn as
sufficient power to govern the nation
and the contamination very much requires
to be governed and there was a consensus
about that the people who oppose the
Constitution later and notice in their
praise who by the way were mostly
members of machine politicians at state
and states especially the Clintons call
in New York they all admitted the
articles of faith that was a consensus
now about this did they go beyond their
brief Madison answers that point in
Federalist Papers and of course as he
does
he doesn't beautiful what he says is the
people have a right to form any kind of
government to watch it they were charged
to amend the articles and they get right
home with one and those guys didn't come
together they get close the windows and
shut the church and close the shutters
for three months from June live Joseph
temper and most of them didn't agree
when they started and now there are two
guys in the back back there in the lower
right who left and inside the document
but everybody else at that road came
together on the document and supported
it the rest of their lives and it was
gratified by false names and the way
they ratified it was really cool I
thought because here's what I gee it was
antsy about the whole thing which were
Wilson ridicules this as a as a
mechanism he says they constructed a
government as it was constructed forward
and more is where you trying to crank
and the highlights around the signing of
those chains and the moon goes around
the earth see he's wearing pruning it
but here's what they really thought
we've got to find a way to make it
strong enough and to keep it straight
and so the way we're going to do it is
everywhere its home representative
principle is really great because as I
say that's a step process right you
can't just make up your mind and do it
right now it's gotta go through a filter
but second the ratification process
because that is part of your criticism I
accept think it's the one calls
beautiful aspects of it because what
they did
they organized it to be popularly
ratified by conventions organized in the
states for that single purpose and then
they would ratify it and then they
adjourn and they never come back into
being again and so that means the people
exercise popularly this mighty power and
then the mechanism by which they did it
is destroyed so they can't exercise such
a value our bread late again so they're
thinking all the time justice by the way
everyone of us give a ring Aristotle's
mineralogy and ethics if you get the
only way to time don't sleep period i'm
down there is it's too bad it's just too
big and i gotta teach that really love
of teaching mostly does have one to read
it but here's what it's like at the
beginning it's all stingy right every
time there is a pain you're supposed to
suffer every time there's a pleasure
you're supposed to curtail it pleasure
is really bad but as the argument goes
along and hope to book the book by the
time we get to the end pleasure is the
whole
point of life because now you've got it
under control so unlike the articles and
see Madison says this in the Federalist
Papers he presents it at one place as a
picture of the proper quartering of the
human soul after all it is our reason
that must be placed in control of the
government our passions must be
controlled by that's in the 49th barrels
but in the 51st Federalist he presents
the Constitution just exactly as it is
presented in the declaration is a
picture of the order of nature God
appears four times in the Declaration
what's this supreme judge of the world
one says divine providence executive
once as the maker of the laws of nature
and of nature's God one says the Creator
like the founder is constitutionally
maker the message is only in the hands
of god of those powers be combined in
the 51st fabulous Madison says what is
government he's explaining these
mechanisms they're in there safe and
Wilson landcruiser effects
% gene he says what is coming up with
the profoundest of all reflections on
human nature if men were angels no
government would be needed if angels
were to govern it neither internal or
external controls on the government
would be necessary I'm saying that you
and Madison responding to the criticism
implicit in your multi-part question
which I said an expert at Aston Madison
response the Declaration of invented is
one of the two direct quotes from the
desperation in federal favors the
Declaration of Independence does say
that the people have right to consent to
the government to take place and they go
for a process to do so the idea that
failed government would prevent us would
prevent them from making and by the way
there isn't any controversy I'm going to
show that this will go ahead Christmas
party there's no controversy about this
bed because how many run a business
right and all of us african guy item
it's an economist and and august how did
he created things and when we learned
from our experiences that we learned
that nothing is perfect and so today we
can look the things that have gone wrong
in government and we can see that the
anti-federalist pretty
they might go on and we can forget that
it's more than 220 years later and that
this is the most successful constitution
in the entire history of man and that
the one that they were supporting was
failing at the time we can forget it and
then we can also forget that the
Constitution United States is not gone
wrong because of some flaw and it it has
been subjected for a hundred years to it
bitter and fierce an ingenious attack by
the group of people who are avowed
enemies of it over and over and over
again and only now this is the final
pragmatic approach and yet even now the
chance of rest Julia and returning to
the beautiful way of gentlemen that it
provides is not lost to us and I'm
saying that we today in this room are
not educated enough are not possessed
but not virtue to make a better knocking
if I wish to cover ourselves that those
fathers made for us because they were
among the tradesmen we lived and so then
if we are to have our greatness as a
people we will return to the beauty to
the discipline of the principles and
institutions that were built for us and
not be smug to think that we can do
something better
some drink others don't you do we now
have rates available and we welcome you
all to join us father of your son both
food and drinks available in the foyer
also the entire building is open for
those of you not had a chance to ponder
group there's a downstairs that I've is
mainly for students it's a lot of
medical facility so the students say
across the street when they're here in
Washington they say the Heritage
Foundation's Johnson dormitory but the
space downstairs with the whole building
with special special first floors from
students the third floor sobbing the
office area then on the fourth floor
there's a terrace a little chilly
tonight court I've also a library feel
free to take a look around and thank you
very much all for coming
you
you